So let's take a look at the last type of market, it's the clone market.
This takes foreign business models and adapts it to local conditions.
What's a foreign business model--typically right now,
a foreign business model is one that's occurring in the US.
What's a local condition?
Well, if the language is different than English or your culture is different than the US
or if your country has import restrictions or your local control and ownership
and you have a market large enough to support a business model.
Typically, a country's worth more than 100 million people that fit this criteria
might be China, India, Russia, Brazil--even though EU itself; just cloning US
business models that exist is not a bad business strategy.